i want to start
in
in a very appropriate
kind of happenstance we have one of the
great
visionaries of making these these uh
making an idea
uh visible to people rick smolen is
gonna start up our conference rick is
the uh innovator the the um kind of
visionary behind the day in the life
photography series
these are those books that they they
have the book is actually only part of
it right the book is only the end result
it's this amazing project that they cook
up where they send thousands of
photographers out around the world uh to
go pursue a project to chronicle
something whether it be the united
states or australia or an idea like
cyberspace or they've done a medicine
book
they're now
engaged in a new idea it's called the
the human face of big data and it's a
project that is going to come out in
book form on november 20th but the the
book form is again just
the tip of what is so amazing about this
project so please join me in welcoming
to our stage to kick off the wired
living by numbers conference
rick smolin
so thomas thank you so much for that
introduction thomas actually uh
gave one of the best
talks that i've seen in recent years
he's very modest but
at ted met several years ago he showed
us how this you go and your doctor sends
you for a blood test and you get this
totally indecipherable piece of paper
back that none of us can even come close
to understanding and he showed us how
just by visualizing it and being able to
show you the last time you did a blood
test and what just basically giving you
a way of taking information that doesn't
mean anything to you
and putting sort of a human face on it
it's really uh it sort of changes the
way that you relate to information so
as tom said i think i have the best job
in the world every
year
i get to invite my heroes and my peers
and some young journalists and we send
them out around the world
to learn about a new topic so about a
year ago
i was
at all things digital i was at ted med
and i was a ted and all my friends in
the technology world every sort of third
uh word that i heard in their
conversation was this word big data
and i said you know what's big data and
it was very interesting because
everybody i spoke to is like the
rorschach test everybody had a
completely different definition of what
it was the first person i spoke to said
big data is so much information doesn't
fit in your laptop and it's like okay
it's not very interesting and then the
next person i asked said no no big data
is taking information from one
organization and then taking information
from another and overlapping them and
seeing these patterns in the data and
again okay i'm a photographer so
that didn't mean much to me and then i
ran into marissa meyer at uh it was at
google and she said rick
big data is like watching the planet
develop a nervous system
i said wait wait say that again and she
said right now all of us with our
smartphones all this data is being
gathered into
through so many different means it's
like watching the planet wake up we're
starting to be able to to measure things
analyze them visualize them and respond
in real time we've never had that
ability before as a as a species
i thought that's really cool and she
even sat down and gave me like five
assignments well how do i take pictures
of that is the people standing in front
of you know servers so i want to take
you for a second
on the journey that i've been uh through
the last year we've had about 200 people
working on this project it's coming out
soon and as thomas said it's many
different things
um so let's see i'm gonna look at this
monitor here okay
so i'm gonna go to my next slide
so um
uh marissa actually pointed me to a
really interesting quote that sort of
put this in perspective because whenever
you talk to people in the big data space
you hear these you know these numbers
which mean absolutely nothing to me so
she pointed me to this really
interesting quote by eric schmidt which
is that all the information generated by
the human race from the dawn of humanity
in 2003 i don't know how eric figured
this out but
is uh five exabytes whatever that means
and then now basically every uh two days
we're generating five exabytes so even
if you don't know what an exabyte is you
can get a pretty good mental picture
this is a straight vertical line
then i saw another interesting quote
which also helped me get a sense of
perspective which is that we're starting
basically to measure everything
everything that can be measured is being
measured and the cost of measuring is
plummeting to almost zero all of us
walking around with our smartphones now
are emitting this whole stream of data
behind us which gets more and more
valuable as all of us are now starting
to create this data
i'm told that when i push this button
there's a delay so i'm sorry and then
finally
all these devices now my friend esther
dyson was telling me that
devices are now generating more
information than we are and the devices
are now starting to change their
behavior based on each other's behavior
so we're not the center of the data
solar system anymore which is actually
also very interesting now until about
six months ago
whenever i saw the story covered by the
media and i'm a journalist so i'm part
of the media or at least i used to be i
always saw the word big data immediately
followed by big brother and uh you know
i'm you know it it's it's
there's certainly every time there's a
new tool there's something you know that
scares people about it it reminds me of
the early days of the internet where uh
i remember and we used to call it
cyberspace back then and uh people are
saying well isn't it just like email
with photographs or is it just a better
way to deliver pornography and yes it's
probably very good at that but it turns
out to be very good to do other things
as well so
i think at the beginning of this journey
i was kind of a little bit skeptical
about this big data thing that i was
hearing everywhere and now i'm sort of a
convert after the the last year
i'm going to keep pushing my buttons
here so um
my son jesse is 10 years old and he
keeps walking into the kitchen at like
two in the morning for a glass of water
because i'm always working around the
clock on this project and about a month
ago he came in and said dad every time i
hear on the phone you're saying big data
this and big data that so what's big
data i'm going oh god how do you tell i
explained this to a 10 year old so i
said um
okay jesse imagine if your whole life
you've been looking through one eye and
all of a sudden for the very first time
scientists enabled you to open up a
second eye so what you're getting is not
just more data but it's actually it's a
different dimension of data and it was
like one of those analogies well dad is
that what computers do it opens up a
second eye i said yeah and he said could
you open up a third eye and a fourth and
a fifth like a thousand eyes and i said
well that's exactly what's happening
we're able to grab information now from
all these different sources and overlap
them and find these actually really
interesting patterns so again the
challenge for us as we're doing this is
how do you photograph this how do you
how do you actually you know make it
something that you and i would care
about how does it affect our parents or
our kids or how it's going to affect our
lives if you go back one slide i'm sorry
now i'm pushing the button too fast
so um
this is an interesting photograph on the
on the left side you see times square at
nine o'clock at night on the right side
you see time square at nine o'clock in
the morning and that this is a wonderful
photographer named stephen wilkes who
does these sort of really interesting
sort of montages
the point of the picture is that
today we are exposed in the course of a
single day
to as much information as somebody from
the 15th century was exposed to in their
entire life again straight vertical line
i'm going to go to the next picture
and also now in the first day of a
baby's life the human race generates 70
times the amount of information in the
library of congress
which is pretty fascinating there's also
this idea that now basically if any of
you are planning to run for president or
any other political office
basically nothing that you do is not
being recorded for posterity so
this stuff doesn't disappear anymore
and obviously the effect of uh you know
this data transparency amplified by
twitter and facebook is having a
dramatic impact on the world of politics
i'm going to give you a couple of
specific examples of things we learned
along the way so last year when that
terrible earthquake hit japan obviously
very devastating something that very few
people heard about is that 43 seconds
before the earthquake hit before it hit
every bullet train every factory in
japan stopped they spent half a billion
dollars installing an early earthquake
warning system
and it worked very effectively imagine
if you'd been on a bullet train when the
earthquake was hitting and then we found
a very interesting story is that a group
of entrepreneurs in palo alto
realized that the accelerometer that's
built into all of our laptops that
senses when your laptop's on the way to
the floor when your kid knocked it off
the table and it pulls the little head
off the platter that same accelerometer
can be used to actually look for
earthquakes so there's a free
crowdsourced ubiquitous global
earthquake early warning system now in
place that cost basically nothing
and what's delightful about it it's
people helping other people just because
they can
joe ito at the at the media lab
created a
radiation detector a lot of people in
japan were very concerned to find out
whether the maps that the japanese
government were giving out were accurate
turns out the the maps were as accurate
as they could make them because
apparently they had a thousand
monitors on 10 foot 10 meter poles well
people all over japan took it into their
own hands to actually measure
the radiation spread and the map that
they came up with that was actually very
different than the one that was the
official map
sorry pushing this button as hard as i
can we could jump to the next slide
in the south pacific a group of
australians are putting
sensors on animals and using the animals
to actually map migration patterns and
ocean currents they put 60 of these
transponders
all over the pacific whenever the
animals get close enough the the data in
the little heads of the elephant seals
here it gets dumped into these
transponders up to the surface and up to
satellites my kids love this just the
idea of using animals to actually map
the planets
this is an interesting story imagine
getting your american express bill
tomorrow your visa bill and there's no
itemization i mean none of us would ever
pay a bill like that right
well but we get electrical bill every
month and we play it blindly because we
have no way of knowing what our devices
are using
sweetheart patel is 27 years old he's a
macarthur fellow and he actually
invented a little device that recognizes
the digital signature of every device in
your house so he can actually tell you
what your electric uh you know uh
what your hairdryer uses up or your
macbook air adapter or your dishwasher
and um what's fascinating about is they
said is there something that you learned
that the average person wouldn't know i
mean that's interesting to get the data
but we still have to pay our bills he
said the average american spends 11
percent of their monthly bill on their
dvr so that little box that spins under
your tv set that we don't pay any
attention to at all
so instead of a new oil well or a
nuclear power plant plant we could just
redesign the dvr
i'm going to go a little bit faster here
because i know we don't have a whole lot
of time there's a
a woman named laura kurgan here in new
york city who looked at the crime data
of new york and basically instead of
looking at where the crimes were
committed she looked at where criminals
lived before they went to jail
and she said maybe this would be a good
place this is where the government the
city of new york spends a million
dollars a year on some of these blocks
in the picture here
the idea is that if you know that
putting people in jail for 20 years
doesn't seem to solve the problem maybe
going to where
criminals are coming from generation
after generation after generation this
would be a good place to put in early
childhood intervention uh career
counseling drug counseling something to
address the problem
and another more story before i get into
the the health side of this talk but for
years radar operators around airports
have been trying to filter out all the
noise from birds and bees and bats and
insects
and a group of anthropologists found out
recently wait wait you have
data from my 15 years of migration
patterns and bats and you've been
throwing it away and i love this is like
to what what from one person is complete
noise we're trying to filter it out to
somebody else as a complete gold mine
and this is uh this is delightful this
is pizza delivery in new york city on a
friday night
this is uh
they put little gps
devices on bicycles so nigel holmes is
one of the world's leading infographic
designers uh was kind enough to actually
design
six uh graphics for us for this book
again showing how google for example
uses data
again i'm going to go really quickly
through these slides
how the world of advertising is changing
how now instead of firing a shotgun off
the sky advertising can now actually
target people and provide the ads to the
people actually interested in those
specific products
the world of twitter and how twitter is
really changing the way that all that
people really have a broadcast network
in their pockets now and can share what
they're thinking in really interesting
ways and some of the insights you know
the the twitterverse
there's this twin deck recently about
actually it turns out to be as accurate
as the gallup poll
so i thought this is a great quote just
to end this part of the of the talk that
marshall mcluhan years ago kind of
predicted that we're going to be
extending our nervous system out around
the planet
so let me tell you on some of the
specific stories about medicine
thomas mentioned in his opening talk 23
and me
so
on the right is yasmine delaware he's
two months pregnant
her dad is from afghanistan her mother
is from italy
she's always been very interested in her
own parentage and so
she very kindly allowed us to she did a
23andme
test and so she's actually able to find
out now
what she's passing on potentially to her
daughter
who's going to be born next month
muhammad ali has parkinson's and
also working together with 23 and me
they've invited 10 000 people around the
world with parkinson's to also
do a 23andme test they're trying to
figure out if there's an expression of
the gene that can be turned on or off by
looking at all these this is very wide
sampling of people with parkinson's
this gentleman discovered that one
percent of the patients in new jersey
were responsible for 33 percent of the
annual health care costs that the same
people were showing up in the emergency
room 50 times a year having all the same
body of tests being done over and over
again
so they actually put a program in place
to make house calls on these people and
it had a dramatic effect simply just
showing up at their houses and actually
addressing the problem instead of
waiting until they came into the
emergency room
this woman on the left ran up a 750 000
bill in one year and she's never been
back once since they actually started
making house calls
thomas also referred to the quantified
self and
i was very fortunate to attend
gary wolf and kevin kelly's quantified
meetup last year in san francisco and
learned a lot about this my mom is going
to be turning 90
in april and she has fallen five times
in the last four years i've actually
fell last week if we could go to the
next slide
my mom my dad died five years ago and uh
we tried to get my mom to move up and
live with us uh here in new york and she
just refused she wanted to live in the
keys in the house where she and my dad
spent many years together
after the third time she fell and they
didn't find her for a couple of hours
i said mom we have to do something we
can't just let this keep happening so i
hired these women to live with her in
shifts which of course she hated so
she's got a stranger sleeping on her
couch
and you know they're stealing my garbage
bags mom they're not stealing the car's
bags
at ted met i ran into a gentleman named
eric dishman who is part of a an
organization between it's a joint
venture between general electric and
intel and one of the things we're
working on is called the magic carpet so
it's a carpet you install in the home of
your loved one
it doesn't say good or bad it just says
this is how rick's mom uh walks when
things are okay
and then all of a sudden in a day where
her balance is off her gate is off or
she hasn't touched the carpet until you
know 10 o'clock in the morning and i
know my mom always has coffee at 8 30 in
the morning
the the the system sends me a message so
there's no cameras no no not invading no
invasion of privacy
nobody's sleeping under couch nobody
stealing your garbage bags
but the product is not out it's still in
research phase and then i found out
about things like this this is the
jawbone
the upband
i know that nike is here and body media
is here
there's all these devices now that kevin
and
gary are going to talk about later that
do kind of the same thing they create a
baseline so every night now my son asked
me dad did you walk through ten thousand
uh feet you know steps today it measures
my sleep at night the idea is that
my friend dean ornish told me that a lot
of doctors believe right now we're
spending 18 percent of our gdp on health
care and if you look at the trend line
they're saying by 2025 it's going to be
40 which is obviously insane we all know
we're paying more and more every month
for our insurance the idea is that three
years before
one of us is in an ambulance on the way
to the hospital our body's been giving
off all kinds of signals and science and
data but we've not been paying attention
to it so one of the ideas is that if we
were wearing devices like this which are
actually kind of fun my brother and i
compare our sleep at night my kids asked
me if i made my goal the gamification of
health instead of dealing with it when
you're already sick but doing it in the
early stages makes this a much maybe
this is a way of sort of addressing the
healthcare
situation
this is a very interesting story
the gates foundation is dedicated to
eradicating uh polio
and in nigeria which has the highest
resurgence of polio in the world
they've found that there are villages
that don't exist on any known maps as
people just keep growing out into the
countryside in order to eradicate pulley
you've actually got to get into every
single family so they're using a
combination of satellite data to find
villages that don't exist on maps
together with
gps enabled cell phones they're
providing the inoculation workers to
triangulate this data and make sure that
every single person is received
a polio
inoculation
a little bit faster here
i'm going to jump this through this one
too
this is another this is one of the
examples that marissa gave me when we
first started working the project
marissa told me that they're actually
able to use satellites now to actually
locate
mosquito eggs on body's water around the
world and i thought this is really funny
it's like using a nuclear bomb to kill a
mosquito but it's using a satellite to
find mosquito eggs
so i said why is that why is that
interesting and she said well basically
instead of spreading ddt and spraying it
over a huge area polluting the water and
a great expense they can actually figure
exactly where the mosquito larvae are
on the body on the surface of water and
only goes to those bodies of water
this is ushahidi it's an organization
that's actually being able to
provide remotely they're able to look at
tweets and text messages and then
actually give healthcare workers in
places like haiti
instant information about where uh
bodies of water where water is needed
where bridges are out areas that um
when when the local infrastructure has
fallen apart they're trying to use data
to actually give people a different view
going here
this one's actually pretty fascinating
too up to 50 percent of the medicine
pharma pharma medicine available in
pharmacies in africa are now a
counterfeit looks exactly like the same
bottles of medicine you and i would buy
but the medicine is actually counterfeit
because it's so profitable
so
there's an organization called m
pedigree which is also backed by the
gates foundation where they put a unique
code on the side of every bottle of
medicine so while you're in the pharmacy
you pay for it but before you leave the
pharmacy you actually text this little
code in the back of the bottle of
medicine it's a one-time use code and it
tells you right away if that's actually
a legitimate bottle of penicillin or
antibiotics whatever the other medicine
is
it's sort of a delightful way of
actually using information to save lives
these doctors at mit discovered that
when you have a heart attack and you're
in the hospital and the doctor comes up
and pushes little button and he prints
out you know 30 seconds of your ekg and
says yeah i think you're looking all
right i think you can go home in a day
or two
it turns out that they looked at
actually 24 hours of the print out this
is actually almost two miles of ekg
paper which they normally do not print
out and they found that there was a very
distinguishable identifiable pattern so
they could actually predict with pretty
uh good regularity who was going to have
another heart attack within two years
and who wasn't
hugo campos has a defibrillator that
actually transmits his data in his house
directly to
his doctor which is pretty interesting
he started keeping track of his exercise
of his diet
and he was trying to correlate his
behavior throughout the day with when
his pacemaker kicked in and he asked the
company that made the uh the device for
a copy of his data and they refused to
give it to him
and it sort of brings up a larger issue
which is like who owns our data why is
it that everybody in the world is sort
of trading our data making money selling
our data and that we seem to have very
little uh say over who's getting it or
who's profiting it from it
it's one of the topics that we actually
talk about in the book as well
this is actually jay walker's book jay
sitting here in front
jay gave one of the most remarkable
talks that ted med two years ago this is
the bills of mortality uh jay tells us
very much better than i do and i'm not
going to tell the whole thing here but
basically this was a book that
in many ways gave birth to the modern
insurance
industry to
it was the first time the human race had
actually used i mean as i'll quote jay
but he talks about the fact this is the
first time that we were able to actually
watch the course of a disease and use
the numbers to actually understand what
was going on instead of the number the
patterns in the sky or the patterns in
our hands but actually use a pattern of
numbers to actually understand what was
going to happen with the disease and
this sort of gave birth to the idea of a
plague curve
if you haven't seen
the talk it's on ted men it's a
wonderful wonderful talk
i'm going to show you one more thing and
then i'm going to jump off stage here
but um
let's see if we can i don't know if you
have sound on this our world using your
smartphone
you can share and compare
map your daily footprint share what
brings you luck get a glimpse into the
one thing people want to experience
during their lifetime and discover
hidden secrets about the world you live
in
curious what your phone can tell you
about your life compare answers with
millions of others globally find your
data doppelganger someone just like you
somewhere else in the world we'll donate
one dollar per download to charity water
for the first 50 000 downloads as a way
to say thank you for participating in
the human face of big data charity water
uses 100 of public donations to directly
fund clean water projects participate in
one of the largest collaborative events
in history and helps measure our world
check out the human face of big
to learn more
so we have an app right now that's
running for two months we allow people
to try to compare and share their lives
to each other one of the things that i
just wanted to say as i'm sort of
finishing up here is um
this project
was made possible by a company called
emc one of the big players in the cloud
space in big data world we're actually
delivering this book to ten thousand key
influencers around the world thanks to
fedex on december 5th which is really
thrilling
these companies have given us the
ability to tell a story it's not about
their products we're not trying there's
no product placement in the book
it's just a very interesting look at a
world that's sort of emerging that i
think is going to give us i think that
the internet was just sort of a stage
going towards big data i think big data
is going to be giving us the ability to
address some of the biggest problems
that are facing the world right now
because we're able to actually measure
things and sense them and respond to
them in real time so thomas thank you
very much and thank you all